she's talking about home improvement
more time spent at home a record number
of people undertaking home improvement
projects
but how can we make sure they're the
type that will pay off
down the line kirsten live in studio
with some tips
all right brian well many people just
want to update their living space aren't
too concerned with whether or not it's
going to be in a future buyer's interest
but plenty of others are looking for
quick projects
that will pay off down the line now the
traditional value generators still apply
upgrades to your kitchen bathroom and
primary suite
but more specific to this day and age
and circumstance
buyers are really valuing things like
turnkey outdoor spaces
dedicated space for home offices and
classrooms
and if you're really lucky a home gym
these features are getting significantly
more value
but don't overlook your outdoor space
some
small cost-effective things would be
adding a little bit of landscaping
getting the backyard green
adding some plants along the fence line
spending a little bit of money to
improve the fencing and getting a little
more privacy to your backyard
could go a long way painting your patio
just some some small things to improve
the overall aesthetic and
and buyers will definitely notice that
eric bildman suggests adding a privacy
door to a room that doesn't have one
like a den or dining room inside your
home that could really give the option
of a
home office or classroom reporting live
i'm
kirstjen joyce denise